I'm gonna test your robotic powers to
the utmost with a trivia quiz or tribute
just to the death uh well let's play
that by ear
okay sure it's true fedora
question one Carl topics 1921 play are
you are introduced the term robot
what does are you are stand for oh oh oh
no times out time's up it's Rossum's
Universal robots yeah you really should
know that he should be very embarrassed
right now I'm gonna give you partial
credit on that one question - who was
the first human to be killed by a robot
and when did it happen you see the dawn
2001 a Space Odyssey a real person who
was the first real person to be killed
by a robot time's up Robert Williams
assembly line worker at a Ford plant in
Flat Rock Michigan struck in the head by
a giant robotic arm and killed in 1979
are you you think that's funny
okay next question next question who is
the actress who played the robot Maria
in Metropolis Oh God oh Ilsa busy
now is busy town wrong Oh Russian no you
don't get partial credit for that
Brigitte Nielsen dated Flavor Flav in
school and so that's just alone okay who
would win in a fight
Voltron or Optimus Prime this is huge
Rocky now that Street by street fight
after this gone wrong Voltron Voltron
combines of powers five different robots
no it's a bat how would you know whoever
combined with another robot there was
that time in Vegas all that's terrible
oh my put that away
this shows the whole store were Brown
shame on you Oh movie our opening on
vinyl question what is the best song to
do the robot dance to what
oh yeah you're correct three two one
now I win my spoons for a bag of flesh
and bones responses puppet
don't forget the border just kidding
but that's not it is to the death that's
not